okay to this video playing casablanca
casablanca from Denmark okay the Queens
gambit yeah the exchanges what I usually
do but maybe vary a bit this is what you
get for varying a line that I don't know
anything about yeah yeah I guess you
play for but it's not like I I know much
yeah I wait I think there is an
interesting gambit line with Bishop c4
94 in castles maybe I can try that and
now I think 95 is the move then Quincy
form the sum is is I think quite
interesting I saw that in him in a in
one of those dangerous weapons books
okay wanna clean h5 if i don't know i
don't know let's just be aggressive okay
look you one maybe yeah might answer of
course some compensation that's that's
clear and in a practical game itself
it's quite uncomfortable for black mmm
do I am doomed should be five on this
just bit too little hmm interesting yeah
it looks like an aggressive position but
i don't really threaten anything or
should I go back to G form and checking
on g7 maybe do something directly g6
Bishop h6 canceled special page six we
are white is very very good compensation
i would have were absolutely hate to
play this is black okay Bishop g7 group
g ade I'm gonna care can I can go to f6
actually very hard to see how black can
should untangle himself maybe you can
take and play a five
b5 can also take here okay let's just
let's just keep pieces on okay so should
I take Queen g5 I can actually take on
e6 am I can take here and I should do
that if I can yeah but I thought I can
can take here on on f7 and rue 57 this
kind of moose or maybe maybe something
else Bishop d7 king of age it's also
very good check okay let's let's keep it
simple check check and let's see I can
take on g2 I mean I saw that but I
wonder if I have a direct made or
anything probably not just chat just
keep that and it's just a piece really
check
maybe you didn't count okay sometimes
you just forget that your piece down it
just really was a very good position
that I got with this gambit quite quite
amazing maybe it's not entirely
sufficient but check it certainly led to
good play in this game check
I mean I have one minute forty four
think I'll manage really check black
resigns yeah Kim yeah I cannot really
advise on the theoretical implications
here I know that this is I believe too
dangerous it feels very dangerous
without castling him so this is this is
probably ok but well don't ask me what
is the right way here to play I don't
know I really don't know i mean i'm
pretty sure that the way it was I was
played in the game like that this should
be quite good company quite good
compensation how is he going to to
untangle himself the computer here
suggests king of a diaz it makes lots of
sense actually try to not weaken
yourself anymore and this is how the
computer already gives a wider winning
advantage yeah I mean it looks it looks
very very dangerous I thought you should
take and play in five yeah this is
indeed still playable so probably this
this idea Bishop g7 wasn't right yeah
the thing is he cannot do anything
anyway so I can probably just improve a
bit maybe something like that Black has
no way to get out of this and after you
went b5 it's probably a probably gone
yeah but should be success winning this
this is too much ok thanks for watching